teaching in the 21st century
increasingly involves technology but how
can educators be sure new high-tech
tools will be a boon and not a bane for
the classroom there's so much noise out
there in the world of Education the
web's is full of stuff teachers don't
have time to go surfing around and
finding things and most of what they
find won't be very good on average well
this looks fun in this looks good but I
have no idea if it's really good because
there's no assessment data so it would
be really nice to actually know whether
some of these things worked or not we
need to build a honest knowledgebase of
what doesn't work what does work and why
the way we have in science itself I call
it making on the science out of
education one area where researchers are
trying to make a science out of
education is with computer games the
goal is to figure out which ones help
students learn and then how to get those
games into the classroom what happens is
you get a grant you develop the game you
test it out on a few classrooms or
whatever it was that you said you do in
the grant as soon as the grant is over
well the game just goes on your shelf
going your little office shelf or it can
go on your personal website or it go
somewhere but it's essentially parked
and there really isn't much of a
mechanism to get that academically
develop content out there and this is
one of the things that I'm really
concerned about because after you've
proven that it's totally changed the
lives of the 40 kids you tested and on
is terrific crime not to have it get out
there and influence more people in
contrast to that video game market is
just huge a single game like World of
Warcraft has 10 million players The Sims
was bought a hundred million times now
contrast to that to the total number of
people in the higher education system
getting degrees every year in math and
science technology and engineering that
number is about 450,000 so we're talking
scales of over ten sometimes over a
hundred that a single game can reach so
we can reach lots and lots and lots of
people and then the question becomes can
we recently some thing that has
pedagogical meaning and that was really
the voyage of discovery for me trying to
figure out where their games could teach
as well as entertain research shows they
can but teachers often don't have time
for games unless they help students
perform better on standardized tests
that's because funding for schools
at least in the United States depends on
test scores what we have now in science
is teaching to lots of bad test cheap
mobile choice word recognition tests
that are destroying science education
for kids the United States so one of our
articles in this issue is going to be
about what we know about assessment and
how can we make tests to be tested or
valid that is testing things we want
kids to know and even more importantly
to me driving teachers to teach
important things about science or about
mathematics rather than things that will
help pass an exam that's measuring the
wrong thing so national and
international testing agencies are
exploring how to use technology to test
more complicated concepts and still
score the responses efficiently but that
will take a lot of money the real
problem I see is that any real progress
to be made in education is a long-term
investment our nation is not very good
at long-term investments and so we don't
ever make the kind of investments that
we really need for long-term success and
long-term success for educational games
requires the same thing money as to
whether the money is coming in it's
coming in little bits but not quite in
the correct buckets and we're to be used
effectively so let me give you an
example a lot of the gains currently
being developed are being developed by
Professor in as grad student we're
starting a little side venture might be
eligible for SBIR money or small
business initiative for research money
that money is about the right size to
finance a game it's about the right
stage in the development of a company to
create its first or second or third game
it certainly would encourage gains for
the scientific community because all the
science agencies have this sbr money but
right now it takes so long to get a
grant approved that these little game
companies go belly-up in the year
waiting for grant before they ever find
out whether
they can make the game or not so even
shortening the time line for review on
some of these grants would open up a lot
of opportunities for creating content
but whether it's games tech based
assessments or any other educational
technology teachers must be sure it will
actually help in their classrooms not be
a distraction or usurp the teachers role
I'm hoping that this issue of science
will help stimulate a conversation about
giving education technology and people
who both use and development development
more effectively study and employed and
recognized as an opportunity but not a
cure-all for our schools teachers need a
much larger voice in a school system and
both in their schools where they need to
work as teams to try to you know produce
a community that will improve their
school but also very importantly in the
school this school district and in the
state which makes most of the education
policy read about educational games tech
based assessment and many other kinds of
educational technology in the January
second issue of science
you
science is published by Triple A yes the
Science Society